hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
let's take a look at a really popular
interview question lru cash
it's even asked by twitch tv it's one of
their most popular interview questions
and also don't forget to like the video
it supports the channel
a lot so this is definitely more of a
design problem than an actual
algorithms problem so we have some kind
of cache
that's going to store values it has a
capacity so it's fixed
size and we want to be able to get
values from this cache based on a
key value if that key value exists
then we'll return the value that it
corresponds to if it doesn't exist the
default value we want to return is
negative one
and if we're getting values we also need
to be able to put values into the
cache we're putting them in based on key
value pairs
and there's a lot of edge cases and they
explain a bit of them to us
if the key already exists in the cache
then
we just want to update the value if it
doesn't already exist then we're
inserting it for the first time so we
can put that key value pair
into the cache and remember this does
have a fixed size capacity
so if we ever exceed the capacity
then we have to evict the least recently
used
so that's why this is called the lru
cash problem
and it also makes sense right if there's
a key that we're not really using
then that's the one that we're going to
take out of the cache
and this is actually pretty similar to
how browsers work
so for example if you're using chrome
and you know
web browsers have caches if there are
values that we're not really using in
those
in that cache then of course we can
remove them let's also try to solve this
the most efficient way which is each of
these operations get
and put are going to be constant time
operations and it's going to be kind of
tricky but
it's definitely possible so let's just
look at the first example so
the input is two so that's something
that we need to
kind of remember right the capacity is
two in this case and the next operation
is put so we're putting a
pair of one one key one value one
and we're going to keep these kind of in
order right because
we want to remove the least recently
used so we got to kind of remember
in what order are we adding these values
in the next one
is another put operation and we're
putting 2 2.
of course for these first three
operations we're not really returning
anything
so the output is going to be null
so next we're actually doing a get
operation
and we want to get the value that has a
key
of one and remember we're trying to do
this as
fast as possible we're trying to do each
operation
in constant time so how can we know
instantly what the value is
when the key is one well the easiest way
to do that would be with a hashmap right
so we're going to use a hashmap to
instantly look up the value of every key
we can of course do this in constant
time and we know that
we the size of this hash map doesn't
need to exceed our capacity so
we can have only two values here right
so for the key value we can use the same
value
that we use for each of our nodes and we
could
and for the value we could also do the
same thing we could use the same
value that we use in our nodes but i'm
going to show you why it's going to be a
little bit
better for us instead to have the value
be a
pointer to the node itself and we can do
the same thing with the second node
that we inserted as well so for key
value 2
we're going to point at this node so now
finally when we call this get and we ask
for the key
1 we're going to return the value 1
that's over here
which is exactly what the output tells
us is correct
so since we just used the get operation
to get this one we went to our key
then we found this value and then we
returned that value
that makes this the most recently used
value and this is the least recently
used value now
so i'm going to keep track of the most
recent and least recent
by having a left and right
pointers right so this left side is
going to be
the least recently used and the right
over here is going to be the most recent
so therefore we're basically going to be
swapping
these two nodes right and so this part
this portion of the problem
is starting to to keep the ordering of
these
it looks like we're going to need a
linked list and
not only a linked list but a double
linked list because remember we can
easily look up where these values are
but if we want to also reorder them
quickly
by by for example every time we use a
get operation we want to take this
value and then move it over here because
it was the most
recent and so now we're going to reorder
the two nodes so now this is the
least recently used and this is the most
recently used
and since this is a doubly linked list
we need
the pointers to be connected of course
the the hashmap won't really need to be
updated because these are pointers
they're already going to be
pointing to the correct ones and i'm not
going to show that and now we can get to
the most
interesting operation the third put so
we're putting a third value
key value 3 3 and since
3 is greater than our capacity
of 2 then we're going to have to remove
the least recently used value and
convenient for us
we know exactly what that value is so
first we're going to end up updating
these pointers
to make the least recently used 1 1
and get rid of this and of course
we want to replace that too since we
know it's the least recently used
we want to replace it with the new key 3
and now we also want to update that
pointer we want it to point at the new
node
and since the new node 3 3 is the most
recent we're
going to put it over here 3 3
and the pointer is going to point here
this pointer is going to point here and
there's going to be a double
link between them so this is basically
the main idea we're going to keep track
of a capacity
we're going to have a double linked list
we're going to have a hash map
where the key of the hashmap is going to
be the same key that we get from the
input and the value is going to be a
pointer
to the nodes and each node is going to
look something like this
and it's going to have two pointers
remember so it's going to have a
previous pointer
and a next pointer and don't forget
about
this right and this left these
are also going to be nodes because
we want to have pointers we want to be
able to instantly know what's the least
recently used and what's the most
recently used so these are going to be
dummy nodes pretty much
so getting into the code remember we're
going to need a
node so before we even write this lru
cache class
let's make another class for that node
that we're going to use
and remember each node is going to have
a key value pair
so we're going to get those we're going
to initialize those
and we're also going to have two
pointers one for the previous node and
one for the next node and they're both
going to initially be set to null
now when we actually get into the lru
class we know that the capacity
needs to be stored because we want to
know if we ever go over that capacity
we also need a hashmap and i'm going to
call that our cache
and remember this is going to map map
the key to nodes
and before we even have any values in
our cache we
want to have a couple dummy pointers a
couple dummy nodes
which tell us what are the most recent
and least recent
uh values that we added so we can just
initialize these to zero
for the default values so zero zero
and initially we want these nodes to be
connected to each other
because if we're inserting a if we're
putting a new node we want to put
it in the middle between left and right
and we can do that with some pointer
stuff
so left dot next is going to be right
and right dot previous is going to be
left and remember left is going to help
us
find the least recently used and
right is going to be most recent
so now let's start with our get function
because it's mostly straightforward
if the key exists so if the key is
in our cache then we can return
that value right so we can return
self dot cash of key
now this tells us the node remember
because
each key is mapped to a node so to get
the value
we can just do dot val and
of course if it doesn't exist they
wanted us to just return
negative one now the only thing we're
forgetting with this
get is that every time we get a
a value we want to update it to the most
recent so to help us with this part i'm
actually going to write a couple helper
functions
so i'm going to write i'm going to write
a remove
and insert helper function and these
helper functions are going to be applied
to our linked list so we're going to
pass in
the node that we want to remove
from our our doubly linked list and i'm
also
going to write a function to insert
into our linked list and when we insert
we're going to insert at
right and the remove is just going to
remove
from the list so
these are basically going to be pointer
functions we're going to be manipulating
some pointers from our left from our
right and doing some stuff so i'm not
even going to worry about that
i'd all i know is that we have a helper
function that can remove
any node from our list and a helper
function that can
insert any node at the rightmost
position of our linked list
so since we're getting what we want to
do to our list
is take this node
self dot cache of key and remove it from
our list
and after we remove it then we want to
reinsert it
at the right most position so we can
just do self
and looking at this get isn't so bad as
long as we fill out
these two helper functions for us so now
when we actually look at our put
function
let's remember that if we have a
key that's already in our cache
that means that a node already exists
in our list with that same key value
so before we can insert this new key
value pair
we want to remove from our
list so we can get that node by
getting our cache and using the key
value
so these helper functions are definitely
coming in handy for us
so now we can create a new node with
this key value pair so node
key value and
we can put that in our hashmap
so now our hashmap has a pointer to this
node
but remember that's not enough we also
have a doubly linked list
so we need to take this node and insert
it into
our list so insert
and just pass in the node which is
cache of the key value so the node is
stored here and we pass that node into
our insert function
okay so we just inserted a new value but
remember
we have a capacity to worry about so
every time we
insert a value we gotta check did does
the
length of our cache now exceed
the capacity if it does
this is the part where we're gonna we're
gonna remove
and delete or evict
the mo the least recently used
so we're going to remove it from the
list
the linked list and delete the lru
from the cache or
the hashmap so how do we actually find
the node for the lru well this is why
we have our left and right pointers
remember the left pointer is all the way
at the left and it's going to
tell us what the least recently used was
so left
left dot next is always going to be
the least recently used and so first
we're going to remove it from our linked
list
by just passing in the node and we're
also going to delete it from
our hashmap so self.cache
and we want the key of this node which
is actually stored in the node itself
this is why we didn't only store the the
value we also store the key in our node
class
so we don't have to return anything
input but we
do now have to fill out these two helper
functions
remove and insert so if you have
three nodes and you want to remove the
middle node
what do you do well you take this
pointer
and move it over here and you take
this pointer and move it over here
so this stuff is no longer relevant
and we have removed the middle node
this is going to be referred to as our
previous node
this is referred to as our next node
so when we're writing this function node
is going to be the middle node so we
want to get the previous
and next nodes of node so we can just
get the pointer so node.previous
node.next
all we want to do is say that previous
dot
next should be updated and next
dot previous should be updated these are
the two pointers
of the next and previous nodes so
previous.next
should be next
next stop previous should be previous
so now node is no longer in between
previous and next the last thing we need
to do is
fill out our insert function which what
we want it to do
is insert a node at the rightmost
position
right before our right pointer
so let's say this is our right pointer
we want to insert right here and this
is going to be our previous pointer so
when we have our
new node that we're trying to insert
what we want to do is take this pointer
and reassign it to that
this pointer and reassign it
over here and we also want this node to
be connected
to its neighbors so we're going to have
the next pointer over here and the
previous pointer
to be here so in this case
our previous and next pointers we can
get
by using our rightmost pointer
so self.write.previous
and self.write now we want both
previous and next to point to node so we
can
do that like this previous dot next
is going to be equal to next dot
previous
which is going to be equal to node
they're both
pointing at node node has been inserted
in the middle of them
and node.next
and node.previous also need to be
assigned
to next and
previous so this is quite a lot of code
about
44 lines with some space and comments in
between but
this is how you get the most optimal
solution
for this problem and of course i had a
bug so
i misspelled something i'm really hoping
that's the only bug here because i do
not want to search for a bug in these
lines of code
okay so we got it to pass so i hope this
was helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon